foreign
Sacramento California and talk to Kayla
what's up Kayla
hi can you hear me I can can you hear me
I can hear you great excellent what's up
um first of all thanks for taking my
call and thank you Jenna for giving me a
call
um I am like super nervous right now I
like never understand why anybody's
nervous when I listen to your show and
now that I'm here I'm like oh my gosh
okay listen it's just you and me and
like millions of other people listening
to this it's not a big deal not scary at
all exactly so okay so I think I'm going
to just give a little bit of background
first and then ask my questions because
it'll make a little bit more sense that
way cool but basically what I'm calling
is
um I have a tendency to be pretty
forgetful
um and
um nothing I mean to me that seems like
out of the norm or you know crazy like
you know I forget where I put things I
forget to respond to texts or send texts
to people
um I'm a stay-at-home mom so you know
during doing certain things around the
house
um non-routine appointments sometimes I
forget those
um and then you know like if I'm meeting
up with a friend I just blank on
everything that we talked about last
time we hung out so anyways
um
but my husband recently has been when we
fight he's been kind of like bringing up
my forgetfulness and you know making it
seem super
um
like bad basically and
um you know he's like I think the reason
why you're forgetting things is because
uh they're not priorities
um and if you just prioritize things
better then you wouldn't forget
um in in my mind you know I'm thinking
okay well
I'm a stay-at-home mom I have two babies
under two and I already struggle with
like anxiety
um and you know especially when I get
super stressed out and I'm having a
conversation with him
um I just freeze up and you know when he
asks me something to remember back to
you know another event I blink I'm like
I have no idea so
anyways basically what I want to know is
you know like could he be right is there
something that I'm not seeing um I
genuinely want to know and
um also how can I just help him
understand where I'm coming from
especially when we're in Conflict when
we're
um fighting I guess awesome great
questions
um so a couple of quick background
questions do you have a trauma
background or no
uh what I mean to find trauma I mean my
parents were divorced and I would say
yes like it was a kind of a catastrophe
my dad describes it as
um for all of my siblings okay I just
wanted to play this out how you told
that
um I think this is important
um uh Define trauma I mean they're
divorced my dad calls it a catastrophe
right
um yeah so we don't have to dig into all
that here's a um
I'm trying to figure out the right place
to start I'm gonna get it a little bit
nerdy and I'm gonna try to keep it as
non-dirty as possible and just know when
I do this my Neuroscience friends all
send me direct messages and they're like
oh my gosh you blew it okay so just know
that I'm not gonna make anybody happy
with this but I think it's important
um okay
the amygdala and the hippocampus are
these little parts of your brain that
help deal with your body's fear response
okay and um hippocampus Works does other
things like memory and spatial
functionings like where are you and it
helps influence emotional regulation all
this stuff but here's what's important
that the parts of your brain that are
are
closely are dealing with is this a fear
is this a threat is there too much
coming into the system at once are also
where a lot of your brain does its
memory storage and retrieval
and that makes sense over time and
memories uh scattered throughout the
brain that's not those aren't the only
two places but here's why that's
important
um think of it this way you can be
watching a football game and you can
look at the game and be like why aren't
they scoring and somebody would look at
you and say Well they're playing defense
right now
like the offense isn't even on the field
they're trying to not let the other team
score right now
and so if you think about a world that
is a body that has been negotiating
trauma for a long time
a body that's anxious
a body that
um has two little kids and is trying to
figure out what just happened to my own
body what happened to my life what
happened to my marriage what happened to
all these things
you have a brain that is decidedly
trying to not die right now and the
thought that it's going to spend energy
making new memories and remembering
things that aren't about not dying
it's very common for people who struggle
with anxiety to have short-term memory
like I just forgot that thing I just I
blew right past it because you got a
body that's just sprinting and fighting
and running for its life that makes
sense
yeah yeah that makes sense
and
okay so and
your husband's got a point
you can't be in relationship if you
forget things all the time
you can't be in a relationship with
somebody else if they have they pour
their heart out to you and you just let
it
you don't do the things Upstream that
make it make you able to hear those
conversations and connect
same with your friends same with
doctor's appointments and so I'm gonna I
want to give you a context not an excuse
okay
you and I could probably spend a couple
hours together and you can tell me some
stories from your pastor that would
probably blow my mind right fair enough
yes okay
um
I want you to know you're not broken
you're not screwed up you have a brain
that's just trying to protect you and it
probably has been for a long time
and
you're a wife
you signed up for a lifetime
relationship you got two little kids you
signed up for two lifetime relationships
and you're just probably a pretty good
friend too right
yeah I try
what a flex yeah I'm gonna try all right
so
um
the healing's gonna be in two ways here
number one
you have to work towards building a
non-anxious life
and that's really hard with two little
kids what does that look like that
probably looks like you for the first
time in your life saying needs out loud
saying I need help with
could you be a part of this I don't like
it when you fill in the blank I really
need a night off tonight
how good are you at saying your needs
out loud
actually I'm pretty good
my husband knows I'm pretty vocal about
my needs
um I just kind of grew up in a family
like that
um are they are they needs are they
demands thank you
that's a good question because I could
demand the dishes get put away in the
right way
that's different than I need some help
yeah I I try my best to format us
questions because I know you know I want
to respect him and I want to you know
not just bully him around but um okay so
I'm gonna stop right there that's the
problem
and people listening are gonna go what
asking questions and being kind
asking questions can be really really
passive aggressive
okay
and I would much rather a couple sit
down not in a fight not in a discussion
but say all right we're entering into
it's Sunday night we're entering into
this week what does this week look like
calendar wise what's this week look like
budget wise
like how are you doing what how can I
love you best this week
and then it's
hey would you pick up the dishes if if I
walk in after a wild day of recording
shows and doing interviews and I walk in
um and then my wife's like hey would you
do that's different than
that because what she's she's not saying
would you she's saying do this and she's
wrapping it up in a nice
pretty package
it would be much I would love to have
some headspace that suggests that I'm
like hey uh I know when I get home I'm
gonna still be fully on and I'm Gonna Be
Still fully participating because we've
already talked about this because she
texted me at 3 P.M saying today's been
hell I need some help when you get home
awesome I'm in see what I'm saying so I
would suggest figuring out a way to be
more direct and y'all do this together a
lot of times folks who have not been
direct but they just talk around it
directness comes out really sharp and
hard and then the other person's like
whoa right so it's just learning how to
say like here's what I need in in a
I guess it's all good just normal
context right
um here's here's the other thing
um
I want you to get really intentional
about writing things down
if you know you struggle with
remembering things then I'm gonna put it
on you to start making plans for how you
can remember things better it's why I I
struggle with anxiety I always I have
for years
I always carry a note card with me
what's with what's going on today
I just keep it with me all the time
because my memory is not trustworthy
I've learned that I forget everything
okay and I still got to change the oil
and I still got to show up to my kids
game and I still gotta go pick up my
daughter from whatever because I said I
would that make sense
so when I say that does that sound like
an attack or is that um do you or do you
know like all right that's fair
you say like
um my husband I don't really know how to
describe this like
it kind of takes me off guard honestly
when if like he did take something
offensive
um you know if I were to like ask him to
do something or whatever
um I think he would prefer me to ask him
um rather than demand it because he's
kind of like this guy that's like you
know I want to feel respected as like
the man of our relationship and
um anyway so asking him to do things
um I don't think he really Minds it
um and he usually responds pretty well
um however
there is something actually as they were
um talking that I remembered is
um one I think our most recent argument
that we had I was like you know after he
was telling me you know you're
forgetting these things and you're just
not prioritizing you know whatever it
was that you said
um he was like uh or I asked him I'm
like can you help me remember you know
can you
um you know because I tried to set
reminders on my phone and
um you know or have him text me a text
message and I'll just leave it unread so
I can always have it on my phone
notifications
um so I try to do things it's just with
our little ones it's not always like
like I'm super distracted all the time
so
um anyway so I asked him I'm like hey
you know can you just remind me you know
like you obviously know that's not a
strengths of mine but it is of yours you
know is that something that you can help
me with and his response to me was you
know I can't just always be doing that
for you and you know like you need to be
self-sufficient and
um you know like I could probably help
you here and there but you you have to
like figure it out pretty much and I was
just like
like when he said that I was honestly
just pretty hurt by it you know because
I'm like okay you're my husband I
thought we're supposed to try and be a
team here and you know it's something
that you're asking you're asking him to
be a parent
yeah
and I want you to start leaning into
this is gonna sound crazy I want you to
start leaning into
not having your life dragged around by
two toddlers
the greatest gift you can give those two
toddlers to infants is you make sure
you're well and I know they got to eat
on a schedule and they gotta sleep I get
that
but the number of kids who run their
households and their parents are left
Haggard and beat down in the wake of
what these kids are demanding and
needing and wanting and all
it's chaos I want you to flip around and
take ownership of that that doesn't mean
you're not going to be exhausted of
course you are doesn't mean you're not
gonna be frustrated of course sure you
got two little ones
but I want you to be on top on the front
end of it not just a passive recipient
and when you ask um and and I didn't I
didn't word this right I'm not saying
make demands of your husband there's a
difference between barking orders
and
passively because here's a good example
you said would you just remind me
and he said no
and you didn't have a comeback for that
other than you were just hurt by it
and so when you ask a question you're
inviting somebody to give their feedback
right they give their answer and that's
not what needs are needs are a gentle I
need some support and help here
and you're also asking them like I said
you're asking to be your dad hey will
you tell me when school starts we we
remind me to change my underwear and to
put on deodorant and brush my teeth like
that like so there is partnership and
there is working together and there's
there is this is a wild season I would
much rather you sit down and say hey I'm
really scared about this
motherhood is is is harder on me than I
thought it was going to be
um I need some help around here I want
to hire some help around here I need a
week once a week I need to go spend some
time with some girlfriends and just not
have kids all over me I need to fill in
the blank like I need these things our
life is really over scheduled right now
and I need a way to take some take some
of the things off the calendar I often
um and there's some great research on
clutter and anxiety
I often am guilty of leaving
a bunch of unread emails a bunch of
unread texts on my phone and it starts
to make me bananas right it's not
actually helping my brain is still
running got to do that thing gotta do
that thing got to do that thing and then
I'm on to the next thing and I'm on to
the next thing and then I get another
text another text another text and so
many of them I've just had to start
saying I'm not going to get back to this
one and I'll just mark it on red
but that's me taking ownership of my
calendar there's two or three unreads
right now and I'll get them before the
end of the day that's that's kind of my
24 hour rule with myself but the more
you allow these things to build and
build and build and build and build
you're just signaling to your body
creating a world that your body can't
exist in just too much just too much too
much too much too much too much so if
you think about unread messages if you
think about about unread texts or
unresponded to emails
just think of somebody knocking on your
door and you don't answer it and you're
just gonna let them keep knocking
because you'll answer them later and
then somebody else starts ringing the
doorbell and then somebody else just
starts yelling through the window and
somebody else just starts calling your
phone
you can't do anything after that and
that's what's happening inside your head
and you just let stuff go let stuff go
let stuff go all I have to say is this
you've created a very anxious world for
yourself and that's super common with
toddlers
and now your husband's getting
frustrated because his world looks
different you're frustrated because your
world looks different and it's time for
you and your husband to get together and
create a whole new world
a whole new planet for how we're gonna
operate here and I want you to practice
remembering practice writing things down
practice leaning into those things and
also practice saying your needs in a
kind gentle way not in a demand way not
in a catching somebody off guardway but
letting people know ahead of time and
um if you find that you're being gaslit
on some things
that your husband's like oh you forgot I
said that maybe he didn't maybe he
didn't and that's where writing things
down is important because you can come
back and if he's kind of jerking you
around a little bit that's important too
um but you're not crazy
you're like an exhausted mom that the
world's just happening to and I want to
encourage you to get some women in your
life that you can walk alongside and
begin to get on top of this of the crest
the wave here right so the water's not
just blasting in the face anymore Crest
the wave here and then you can start to
take ownership of the calendars take
ownership of these kids routines take
ownership of what you need in your home
and asking for those needs and then take
ownership of I forget stuff a lot so I'm
going to start leaning into some
practices where I can start remembering
things a little bit better you're on the
right path you're on the right path
thanks for the call Kayla